hi today I'd like to talk to you about
polls last time I ended up talking to
you about LTI representations and
manipulations and in particular I want
to emphasis emphasize the relationship
between feed-forward and feedback
systems in order to segue us into polls
using what we know about that
relationship we can find the base of a
geometric sequence and that geometric
sequence actually represents the
long-term response of our system to a
unit sample response or a delta that
value is also what we refer to as the
poles at this point I'll go over how to
solve for them and very basic properties
of them so that we can use the
information that we have about the poles
to try to actually predict the future or
look at the long-term behavior of our
system first a quick review last time we
talked about feed-forward systems and in
particular I want to emphasize the fact
that if you have a transient input to
your feed-forward system you're going to
end up with a transient response there's
no method by which a feed-forward system
can retain information over more than
the amount of time steps that you feed
information into it feedback systems on
the other hand represent a persistent
response to a transient input because
you're working with a feedback system
information that you put in can be
reflected in more than one time step and
possibly you know multiple time steps
depending upon how many delays you have
working in your feedback system last
time I also drew out the relationship
between feed-forward and feedback
systems you can actually turn a feedback
system or talk about a feedback system
in terms of a feed-forward system that
takes infinite samples of the input and
feeds them through a summation that
takes infinite delays through your
system you can represent that
translation using a geometric sequence
the basis of that geometric sequence is
the object that we're going to use in
order to predict the future and that's
what we're talking about when we talk
about poles
you can't have multiple geometric
sequences involved in actually
determining the long-term behaviour your
system if you only have one then things
are pretty simple you find your system
function you find the value associated
with P Zero in this expression it's okay
if there's some sort of scalar on the
outside of this expression right we're
working with linear time-invariant
system so that scalar is going to affect
the initial response to your system but
in terms of the long-term behavior it
doesn't matter as much so don't worry
about it right now
relatedly if you're solving for these
expressions in second or higher order
systems you're going to end up having to
solve partial fractions you can do this
and in part one of the reasons that you
would want to do this is so that you can
get out those scalars if you're going to
be talking about the very short-term
response to something like a transient
input we're not going to be too
interested in those in this course we're
mostly going to be talking about
long-term response so we can get around
the fact that we're dealing with higher
order systems and not solving partial
fractions by substituting in for an
expression called Z which actually
represents the inverse power of art and
then solving for the roots of that
equation if you substitute Z in for one
over R in this denominator and then
solve for the root associated with that
expression you'll get the same result
you'll actually end up out with P Zero
all right so now we know how to find the
pole or multiple poles if we're
interested in multiple poles what do we
do now I still haven't gone over how to
figure out the long-term behavior of
your system the first thing you do is
look at the magnitude of all the poles
that you solved for and
select the polls with the largest
magnitude if there are multiple polls
with the same magnitude then you'll end
up looking at all of them if you have
different properties and the ones here
you can end up with some you know
complex behavior I would not worry about
that too much
or you know I would ask a professor or a
TA when that happens but in the general
sense if your dominant poll has a
magnitude greater than one then you're
gonna say long-term divergence in your
system this makes sense if you think
about it if at every time step your unit
sample response is multiplied by a value
that is greater than one then it's going
to increase and in fact the extent to
which the magnitude of your dominant
pole is greater than one is going to
determine your rate of increase and also
determine how fast your envelope
explodes similarly if the magnitude of
your dominant pole is less than one then
in response to a unit sample input or a
delta your system is going to converge
this also makes sense intuitively if you
are progressively multiplying the values
in your system by a scalar that is less
than one then eventually you're going to
end up converging to zero it's a cover
the only category we haven't talked
about if your dominant pole is actually
equal in magnitude to one then you're
not going to see convergence or
divergence and this is one of the places
in which the magnitude of the scalar
that you end up multiplying your system
by can become relevant we're not going
to focus on this situation too much but
it's good to know what actually happens
when the magnitude of your dominant pole
is equal to one the other feature that
we're interested in when we're looking
at the magnitude of when we're looking
at the dominant pole of a system
is if we were to represent the dominant
pole in this form what the angle
associated with that pole is if you were
to graph that pole on the complex plane
using polar coordinates if your pole
stays on the real axis or if your pole
does not have a complex component then
you'll see one of two things the first
thing that it's possible for you to see
is that you'll get absolutely non
alternating behavior right your system
response stays on one side of the x axis
and either converges diverges or remains
constant as a consequence of input of
the unit-sample and you won't see any
sort of alternating or oscillating
behavior this only happens when the your
dominant pole is real and positive if
your dominant pole is real and or and
negative this also means that it's still
on the real axis but its value is
negative so if you're looking at polar
coordinates it's going to have an angle
pi associated with it this means you get
alternating behavior and what I mean
when I say alternating behavior is that
your unit-sample response is going to
jump across the x axis at every time
step this is also equivalent to having a
period of two the other situation you
can run into is that this angle is
neither 0 nor pi and at that point
you're going to be talking about
oscillatory behavior or a sinusoidal
response that retains its edges at the
envelope of your function in order to
find the period or in order to find the
amount of time it takes for your unit
sample response to complete one period
you're going to take the angle
associated with your dominant pole and
divide 2pi by it this is the general
equation for a period this covers the
basics of what you want to do once you
already have your poles next time I'm
actually going to solve a pole problem
and show you what the long-term response
looks like and also talk about some
things about poles
you know pretty much skimmed over and at
that point you should be able to solve
and look at bowls for yourself